[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno quieres aquí han visto el interior
de su cuerpo
voy a mucha gente que no alza la mano
los que no han alzado la mano cuenten me
quiere de ustedes se han fracturado y
les han tomado una imagen de rayos x
si ven la mayoría de nosotros hemos
tenido la experiencia de ver el interior
de nuestro cuerpo o el de alguien más
algunos de pronto no han tenido esa
experiencia pero para quienes lo hemos
hecho compartirán la emoción y la
maravilla de verse a sí mismos desde su
funcionamiento interno
cuando yo fui expuesta a estas imágenes
médicas por primera vez era estudiante
de ingeniería biomédica en medellín
y en ese momento mi sueño era y yo decía
yo quiero crear herramientas para
solucionar problemas clínicos y hoy
quiero contarles sobre una de estas
herramientas pero antes de eso voy a
compartirles dos anécdotas que
sucedieron en los inicios de mi carrera
dos anécdotas que aparentemente no están
conectadas pero que realmente han
marcado mi vida la primera de esas fue
que por casualidades del destino en la
universidad terminé tomando una clase
sobre apreciación del arte y sin saber
en qué se relacionaba la apreciación del
arte con la ingeniería biomédica aprendí
que la pintura y el arte son una forma
de guardar la historia es impresionante
hoy en día la conexión que tenemos con
la con guardar la historia a través de
la fotografía digital aquí todos nos
encanta tomar las fotos en los eventos
con nuestras familias y realmente las
fotos son ricas en emociones las fotos
son la representación de nuestra
historia hacia otras generaciones
fotos son conocimientos en sí
el segundo evento que marcó mi vida fue
definitivamente la clase de física en
esta clase yo tuve la tarea y fue la
primera vez que empecé a ver las
imágenes de ultrasonido tuve la tarea de
aprender y preparar una presentación
sobre los principios de la clase de
física que se aplican en las imágenes de
ultrasonido entonces imagínense tú vas a
biblioteca abres el libro empieza a
investigar cuando yo vi esas imágenes de
ultrasonido detallando el interior de
nuestro cuerpo fue absolutamente
fascinante por ejemplo este vídeo que
está aquí es un vídeo que se forma a
través del ultrasonido de nuestro
corazón nuestro corazón es también un
órgano muy fascinante en promedio late
70 veces por minuto y en el transcurso
de nuestra vida nunca deja de funcionar
imagínense cuando ya el corazón deja de
funcionar llega a latir a hasta 2 mil
millones de veces 12 eventos
interesantes no les parece por un lado
tenemos la fotografía que nos muestran
cosas
vemos directamente con nuestros ojos
personas familias lugares escenas y por
otro lado tenemos las imágenes de
ultrasonido que son unas ilustraciones
del interior de nuestro cuerpo y lo
interesante es que el interior de
nuestro cuerpo no lo podemos ver
directamente con nuestros ojos entonces
en este momento mi curiosidad era muy
grande y yo decía que hace el
ultrasonido como hacen estas máquinas
para ver dentro de nuestro cuerpo
en el transcurso de mi carrera en la
universidad aprendí de que la luz es lo
que permite que formemos
representaciones visuales del exterior
la luz choca con los objetos se refleja
hacia nuestros ojos y nuestro cerebro
crea las imágenes todo lo que podemos
ver
si no hay luz no podemos ver lo que
tenemos enfrente aunque los objetos
seguirán estando allí y así como la luz
nos permite ver el sonido es lo que nos
permite ver dentro de la barriga de
nuestra madre y observar por primera vez
la primera imagen de todos como seres
vivos es así todas las nuevas
generaciones la primera imagen la
primera foto que tienen en este mundo es
una imagen de ultrasonido pero más allá
que una imagen esta vídeo nos permite
ver que nuestro corazón está latiendo
que nuestro crecimiento sea el adecuado
hoy en día cuando mis dos queridos
hermanos me dan la gran noticia de que
voy a hacer tía y me muestran las
imágenes de ultrasonido obviamente mi
felicidad es gigante y cuando yo veo
estas imágenes también veo esto veo
señales veo ondas y cantidades de
algoritmos que tienen que suceder en
estas máquinas para producir las
imágenes
a continuación quiero llevarlos por la
travesía en emprender un salto en la
historia del ultrasonido y revolucionar
completamente sus luego de mi carrera
universitaria del pregrado yo emprendí
una travesía hacia los eeuu porque yo
quería saber más sobre el ultrasonido
entonces ingresé a un doctorado en
ciencias biomédicas en la clínica mayo y
en ese momento como todo evoluciona mi
curiosidad también evolucionó yo decía
sí es excelente poder ver el interior de
nuestro cuerpo pero cómo podemos ir más
allá de ver estas formas y estas
estructuras cómo podemos usar el
ultrasonido para saber si nuestro cuerpo
está enfermo
y para responder a estas preguntas es
necesario que seamos específicos en qué
tipo de enfermedad queremos ver y que el
ultrasonido convencional no nos permite
ver esa información es aquí donde he
enfocado todas mis investigaciones en
una es muy grande y es acerca de la
fibrosis del hígado resulta que más de
325 millones de personas en el mundo
tienen fibrosis de hígado imagínense 325
millones es equivalente a 6 veces la
población de colombia es una cantidad
grandísima de gente la fibrosis delgado
sucede por el virus de la hepatitis por
la obesidad y por el abuso de alcohol
cada vez que esto sucede en nuestro
cuerpo se enferma y el hígado se
comienza a auto reparar y forma pequeñas
cicatrices estas cicatrices se acumulan
y forman la fibrosis de hígado como
consecuencia a nuestro hígado se pone
muy muy duro y no puede funcionar
correctamente y esto lleva a problemas
más graves como el cáncer de hígado
entonces cómo hacemos para saber en la
actualidad para saber si tenemos
fibrosis de hígado
tenemos que ir acudir a un método
invasivo que se llama la biopsia en este
método por medio de una aguja se pincha
a nuestro abdomen y la web tiene que
entrar en nuestro cuerpo aproximadamente
46 centímetros llegar al hígado y tomar
un pedacito este pedacito se lleva al
laboratorio y un especialista en
patología nos da la respuesta imagínense
que con esta aguja hay consecuencias
como por ejemplo infecciones pueden
haber hemorragias pero lo más
desconcertante es que sólo dos de cada
diez biopsias dan resultados efectivos
sigamos entonces en la travesía de
revolucionar el ultrasonido cómo se usa
el ultrasonido para saber si nuestro
hígado está enfermo
la revolución del ultrasonido comienza
desde lo básico desde lo simple la
palpación durante siglos los médicos
aplican movimiento y presión con sus
manos para sentir si nuestro cuerpo está
enfermo
cuando yo sientes que sienten que
ciertos órganos están duros eso es una
alerta de que algo está mal
esto se está poniendo muy interesante no
les parece hace unos minutos hablábamos
de cómo la luz nos permite ver el
exterior como el sonido nos permite ver
el interior será entonces que el
movimiento nos permitirá ver si nuestros
órganos de nuestro hígado está enfermo
ven esta imagen
recuerden que les dije que la clase de
física fue fundamental para mi vida esta
es una imagen clásica del movimiento son
las ondas y esto todos aquí la mayoría
lo podemos hacer tomando una piedra y la
tiramos al agua ese movimiento en el
agua es el movimiento de las ondas
matemáticamente se describe por la
ecuación de las ondas quienes aquí han
visto esta ecuación antes
aquí si no veo que como mucha gente alza
la habana pero no se preocupen para los
matemáticos y físicos esta es una
ecuación diferencial de segundo orden lo
importante es que hoy yo quiero que
entendamos dos cositas esta ecuación nos
dicen primero cuando los materiales son
muy duros
este movimiento de las ondas sucede muy
rápido y segundo cuando los materiales
son muy blanditos el movimiento de las
ondas es muy lento
entonces ustedes dirán que tiene que ver
esta ecuación con la fibrosis del hígado
aquí empieza la revolución
si logramos generar este tipo de ondas
de nuestro hígado y medir si se mueven
rápidos o lentos podremos saber sin
necesidad de agujas sin riesgo de
infecciones si nuestro hígado está
enfermo
por más de 10 años estoy trabajando en
colaboración colaboración con muchos
científicos de todos los países del
mundo desarrollando el método basada en
ultrasonido que está revolucionando las
imágenes médicas
este método se llama la elastografía de
ultrasonido y quiero contarles cómo
funciona en tres pasos
primero tenemos que generar este tipo de
ondas en nuestro hígado suena tan fácil
como tirar la piedra al agua no les
parece pero como lo hacemos dentro de
nuestro cuerpo recuerden que el
ultrasonido es un poder que nos deja ver
dentro de nuestro cuerpo le voy a contar
una pequeña historia en 1990 un
científico ruso de apellido serveis john
en su laboratorio de acústica con unos
tanques grandes de agua y lo que
llamamos unos transductores que generan
sonido tenía una esfera chiquitita
enfrente del transductor y el mostró que
el sonido es capaz de mover esta esfera
y crear las mismas ondas que vemos en el
agua cuando tiramos la piedra esto es
magnífico luego de que se generan las
ondas el segundo paso es
detectar las ondas si ya logramos
generar las ondas dentro del hígado cómo
podemos verlas aquí es donde se usa el
ultrasonido convencional esas imágenes a
blanco y negro que vemos lo que hacemos
es que tomamos muchas muchas muchas
imágenes para poder ver cómo se causan
estas ondas dentro del hígado y
finalmente tenemos que calcular la
velocidad
aquí es donde vuelve otra vez la famosa
clase de física que me persigue toda
hora por todos lados y en la clase de
física nos enseñan la definición de
velocidad y dicen que es la relación
entre el cambio del espacio al cambio
del tiempo estas son señales de
movimiento de ondas dentro de un hígado
que muestran cómo cambian en el tiempo y
cada línea de color muestran cómo cambia
en el espacio
aquí podemos observar dos imágenes
clásicas de ultrasonido en un hígado
sano un hígado saludable y un hígado
enfermo algunos de ustedes nota la
diferencia
notan que son diferentes es
luego con la elastografía la ventana y
las revoluciones que podemos ver mucho
más ya no pasamos a estar limitados por
la escala de grises ahora tenemos una
escala de colores y el color nos
representa el valor de la elasticidad
entonces en este caso el color azul
representa el hígado sano del hígado
saludable y el color verde representa el
hígado con fibrosis si notan unos puntos
amarillos y rojos en la imagen verde
esas son la acumulación de cicatrices
que les agarraba les comentaba al
principio que forman la fibrosis
hoy luego de 18 años que comencé mi
carrera en ingeniería biomédica estoy
cumpliendo mi sueño de crear
herramientas para solucionar problemas
clínicos
los científicos desarrollamos estas
herramientas en los laboratorios en las
universidades pero para que estas
herramientas lleguen a cada persona
tienen que pasar muchísimos años y es
importante desarrollar estrategias y
alianzas con las grandes empresas las
grandes industrias que tienen la
plataforma y el poder de comercializar
esta tecnología es por eso que hace poco
hice una transición de mi carrera como
científica en un laboratorio en una
universidad a ser científica en una gran
empresa que produce máquinas de
ultrasonido y aquí trabajó de la mano
con ellos para llevar que la fotografía
sea un examen rutinario y que estos 325
millones de personas que tienen fibrosis
hoy gracias al ultrasonido con la
fotografía sin necesidad de agujas sin
riesgos de hemorragia puedan saber si su
hígado está sano
está enfermo y lo más importante lo
puedan saber con una certeza muy grande
mi sueño sigue y con él me llevo todas
las oportunidades de encontrar nuevas
aplicaciones y crear nuevos métodos que
van a seguir revolucionando el futuro de
la medicina muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]